all right let's talk about something
very very disturbing
um
not that joe biden called the reporter a
son of a [ __ ] we'll get to that we'll
get to that but i'm finding that to be
in poor taste but not actually scary and
disturbing the following is scary and
disturbing republicans are now openly
saying
openly saying
if they win the house of representatives
in november and take control in january
of 2023
they will look to subpoena
potentially prosecute and maybe imprison
members of congress participating in the
january 6th committee investigating the
trump riots of last year
when they say this stuff we should take
them seriously rather than saying
no
now
when they told us what they were
planning for the 2020 presidential
they did it we should have taken it more
seriously and we should be taking this
more seriously now so i'm going to play
a clip for you of newt gingrich newt
gingrich was the speaker of the house in
1994 ushered in
significant acceleration in the
republican party's abandonment of policy
and moving into cultural issues and and
the like we've talked about his role uh
in that significantly you can check out
my interview with noam chomsky where we
talk about newt gingrich's role
one of the things that we have heard
from republicans is that if they win the
house in 2022 they will impeach joe
biden and i believe that they certainly
will try but here is something
extraordinarily dystopian from newt
gingrich and again just we have no
reason to doubt him here he is uh you're
going to have a republican majority in
the house and republican majority in the
senate and all these people who've been
so tough and so mean and so nasty are
going to be delivered subpoenas for
every document every conversation every
tweet every email uh because i think
it's clear that this these are people
who are literally just running over the
law
pursuing innocent people causing them to
spend thousands and thousands of dollars
in legal fees for no justification and
it's basically a lynch mob and
unfortunately the attorney general
united states has joined that lynch mob
and is totally misusing the fbi and i
think when you have a republican
congress this is all going to come
crashing down and the wolves are going
to find out that they're now sheep and
they're the ones who are in fact going
to i think face a real risk of jail for
the kind of laws they're breaking
participating in the duly impaneled
investigation
of one of the most disgusting events of
the last five years in the united states
if newt gingrich got his way and he's
not running but he's still a powerful
figure in the republican party
might put some of those investigators
in jail
folks when they tell you what they're
going to do or what they're going to try
to do
take them seriously that is a lesson
from the 2020 presidential election take
them seriously even republican
congresswoman liz cheney issued a
warning over this she retweeted the
gingrich video we just played and added
the comment quote a former speaker of
the house
is threatening jail time for members of
congress who are investigating the
violent january 6 attack on our capital
and our constitution this is what it
looks like
when the rule of law unravels
now liz cheney is one of only two
republicans on that committee doing the
investigation so she may feel as though
she is now in the crosshairs and may
have a personal interest in this for
sure
but this is an idea that republicans are
liking here is video of matt gates
appearing on
real america's voice
war room this might even be his show i'm
so confused by this channel this may be
matt gates own show listen to what he
had to say about it now you have the
january 6 event where i expect that
there will be these shadowy gray area
national security types that are in and
around the activation of the increase in
criminal acuity of that day and not for
nothing steve but using a cut out seems
like exactly what they were trying to do
to me now note this is all
conspiratorial type stuff about the
people doing the investigating or the
ones responsible for the right it's
crazy but let's continue to listen
because it tells us what a state of mind
is when it comes to this stuff
there's a guy named steve alford who's
sitting in prison right now for trying
to extort me but he was not acting alone
very likely he was answering to a cut
out someone like bob kent to try to
destroy me because you know what newt's
right we are going to take power and
when we do it's not going to be the days
of paul ryan and trey gowdy where the
republicans go limp wristed where they
lose their backbone and fail to send a
single subpoena it limp wristed is that
a homophobic uh phrase i i'm not super
familiar with it but it strikes me as
potentially homophobic let me know yeah
no it's going to be the days of jim
jordan and matt gates and marjorie
taylor green and you know what we're
going to get answers real answers about
what about what happened in the election
answers about the wuhan institute of
virology and certainly answers about a
department of justice and a national
security apparatus that has gone totally
off the rails they have become the
enforcement wing of the democratic party
the entire country knows it and you know
what we need honest fair real
application of the laws in our country
we're not getting that now and frankly
we weren't really getting it at the doj
under president trump there's so listen
you've got to take them seriously just
believe what they're telling you if
they're telling you they're going to do
this stuff then we have to listen and we
have to take it seriously because
they seem to really try to do it whether
they get away with it is a different
question you know they tried the 2020
stuff
when you look back and think about 20 20
20 they they tried every aspect of it
they tried the fake elector stuff
they tried pressuring local officials
they tried stopping the count versus
starting the count as convenient to them
uh they at least it was in the
conversation about uh declaring a
national emergency slash martial law
although they'll they'll say they
weren't really close to doing it which
may be true but it was part of the
discussion we know that multiple people
have told us they're telling us what
they're going to do and we have to take
it really seriously
they will try to jail their political
adversaries and they're admitting that
that's what they're going to try to do
we've got to be really really concerned
about it and not let our guard down in
2022
is particularly consequential because of
that